are you excited about the new christmas
tradition that we the new the newest
christmas tradition
the annual kevin spacey yeah dude
honestly what's funny is
so right before i left for my vacation
i i because on night wave it's we have
two christmas traditions
we have uh we we i was just playing the
same kevin spacey video every year
uh and then of course viper the snowman
now
i played the spacey one like as i left
and it was my sign
like my goodbye farewell have a good
christmas let's play the spacey kill him
with kindness video
without any idea that i would be greeted
on christmas day with
with another gift from from wonderful
wonderful mr spacey here we go
that's right what would christmas eve
be without a message from me it's true
that's right what would christmas eve be
without a message for me
look this past year
i've listen
a lot of people have reached out to me
this past year
and have shared their own struggles
and my ability to be there for them
really only been possible because of my
own difficulties
and while it's been a privilege to offer
support
i have to say frankly it's also been
beyond my abilities and it's bigger than
me
because heartbreakingly so many
have talked about things having gotten
so bad for them
that they've contemplated taking their
own lives and that's enough for me to
want to take an entirely different
approach this year
to acknowledge their pain and say to
anyone out there who's struggling
what's up with his uh his lip
um i don't know it's definitely that
doesn't look like a herp
or anything it looks like bruising
you might have been like an aggressive
mouth [ __ ] at christmas time i like to
hi young usually my lawn guy and uh pay
him to bite my lip
while i jack off furiously and call him
racial slurs that don't even fit his
actual nationality
we're contemplating that idea please
please do not take that step
if you're standing in a place that you
can no longer remain standing if you're
suffering if you need help if you feel
guilt or shame
if you're struck if i [ __ ] you and i
forgot about you
struggling with your identity if your
back's up against the wall
if i had if i [ __ ] your mouth and
promised your hollywood career and then
this stuff came out and now you don't
get to be on house of cards perhaps i'll
charge a mouth
in an suv off my movie set in nantucket
you know there was was a kevin spacey
from nantucket
perhaps you're a gay fellow that was in
the star trek movie
perhaps you you're endazed and confused
and you remember
when you were 13 and you were dazed and
confused as i tried to pin you down
in that bed or if you feel that
there is no path for you whatever your
situation i promise you there is a path
and that at this time during this
holiday and beyond
even if you don't feel it there are
people out there who understand and who
can help
because you are not alone
the only way this would have been better
is if he sang that song you are not
you and by other
notorious michael jackson i am here with
you
everyone i was always more of a fan of
man in the mirror
a merry christmas a great 20 21
and say to all those out there who might
be suffering
it gets better better
it does get yes thank you kevin happy
holidays everyone
can i just say something too i is he
[ __ ] with us
you know what because everything he does
i think he's [ __ ] with you you know
what's super [ __ ] up is that's
actually how i ended the last night wave
was saying like i played a spacey video
jokingly
but not this one and then i was like you
know hey just a heads up you know if
if it does get rough you know reach out
to somebody whatever but
um there was he's definitely
a piece of [ __ ] he's definitely i don't
know if he's genuinely trying to rehab
his image or if he's [ __ ] with people
i think he's [ __ ] with people
i don't think i'm leaning towards him
[ __ ] with people because he's just
evil right but look i'm gonna i'm gonna
take a [ __ ]
[Music]
you know i know people uh edgy stance
but i i have to
say and i mean this i'm i'm turning a
corner on kevin's face
i think i gotta be honest with you i
want to be honest with you
i was thinking the same thing rules i'm
sorry
look if the if the world's gonna be
a place full of good movies and tv and
all that kind of we're gonna have to let
a couple of
really bad people get a pass
and i'm not saying all of them there's a
lot of people that don't need to get a
pass but kevin spacey
i vote kevin spacey you don't believe me
watch the last season in the house of
cards and tell me it didn't need him in
it
i know how about that no how about just
no i
when you talk about a show i have no
desire to see the last season of
and i mean nobody talks about it nobody
cares about that last season
um buzzer bali's song goes i prefer them
politely threatening people remember the
fireplace was one of the best videos
it really was a great video uh there was
a whole it was funny man because
most of twitter was obviously like um
maybe
don't like there were so many people
like
uh kevin maybe don't maybe be sensitive
that people don't want to see and it's
like
this man supposedly tried to young
anthony rap at a party like this guy's a
predator
and you're like uh maybe i don't know
like think about people's feelings like
this is people on twitter and i'm going
he's [ __ ] like there were people that
were taking him literally
oh yeah of course and then going uh
maybe you're not trolling
maybe you're not the guy we should be
hearing that message from and it's like
he knows that you dumb [ __ ] i'm
i i'm [ __ ] i'm pro-spacey now
and if anybody's like i don't want there
to be any confusion like oh you know
oh is it just an edgy boy stance or
whatever listen
i am unironically pro kevin spacey now
he [ __ ] rules in my opinion
um hey maybe we'll get him on the show
he's not doing anything
i mean would i mean
would that really be that out of the
question
probably not i think we could pull that
off i don't know he only does this one
video a year and i mean again he doesn't
need to [ __ ] work ever again so you
know
he's not it's not like he's ever going
to starve you know the guy's [ __ ]
loaded he has plenty of money he's still
getting residual checks and all that
um i don't think he's ever going gonna
make a comeback though
um because you know some people
eventually get the alrighty serve this
time or whatever but i don't think kevin
spacey's ever gonna be called back to do
a movie
you know you don't think so he's so good
though like i
look i'm not obviously he did some bad
stuff
but he's really good he's a very good
actor
he's really good
um i don't i don't know i don't know man
i i really am spacey's just growing on
me because it's like
you know most people do the the
apologetic tour and they're like look
i'm humbled and you know i was
drinking and doing coke you know i had
some rough years but i'm
i'm on the path and i almost respect him
like just tripling down on it
you know like there's just something
about that that i just love i mean keep
in mind this is this is the guy remember
remember this is the guy that when he
was
when word was getting out about his uh
his
activities let's say um
he was he was the one that was like uh
they were like look man kevin spacey you
know
or whatever kevin spacey did this to me
and then what
kevin spacey was like i think now is a
perfect time to come out and say that i
am a gay man
he's just i love him he's a [ __ ]
psychopath i love him